[Music]
could i go to you back to you first and
say you're hearing um a proposal there
an agenda you might always say from alex
which talks about the way in which we
can practically and meaningfully use
these sorts of techniques uh in a way
that relates to our own personal
experience links to wider society i mean
surely that's something we should all
welcome there's nothing uh problematic
about that is there
no of course there's nothing problematic
about that that i mean
where
where
and i i'm not sure whether i'm
interpreting
mindfulness
properly
um
i would say that
uh
that the the negative emotions are are
often as useful as the positive ones
so if you're living in a very um unequal
uh discriminatory society
anger
um
although it may not always be as
uh
useful in talking to cabinet ministers
as you said um
it seems necessary to me it seems
necessary to be angry about inequality
and about poverty and about over
consumption and
um all that kind of stuff and and so i
would
i would argue
for the negative emotions to to a large
extent i mean not exclusively
i mean i keep thinking of um t.h white
who wrote the sword in stone
uh there's a wonderful line that merlin
has where he says the best thing for
being sad is to learn something
um you know a positive use of of
negative emotions uh you know who could
argue with that but on the other hand i
wouldn't want to get rid of
um
rage in society particularly when our
society is so completely dysfunctional
could i throw a version of that thought
back to peter because peter if you as i
understand it when you look back at the
original
buddhist texts from which
what our contemporary idea of
mindfulness is drawn from a lot of them
are really not at all about what the
contemporary world makes mindfulness
about which is about calming down
breathing hard providing positive
emotions they're actually about trying
to avoid the terror of non-being it's
very much a kind of mitigation strategy
rather than a positivity strategy and i
wonder if that's a useful way to try and
link that question of responsibility the
fact that we have to actually
acknowledge that there are many negative
things in the world with what we can do
personally and individually in terms of
improving our own personal happiness in
other words overcoming the temptation to
look inward and say i'm doing fine the
rest of the world can go hang
yes
um
well it what i think what has happened
here is that uh
mindfulness
as as it's been presented especially
um through the what the translation
really of the tradition
um into kind of secular and therapeutic
registers through the work of uh john
cabinson for example um has tended to
abstract part of the tradition
um
and the receiving culture here
well when i say
america the uk whatever um it's been
received into a culture that has a
history
of
taking
psychological uh techniques you know the
whole positive psychology movement um
and tending to
over emphasize
uh the need to cultivate the positive
and uh at the expense sometimes of uh
repressing or
zoning out you know it can lead to a
kind of a passive rather individualized
uh opting out
um
there is
value i think in the possibility of
cultivating
less of an identification with these
emotions whether they're good or bad and
being able to respond more
productively and maybe more critically
in the world as well
if we're able to
reduce our identification with these
emotions
and respond from a place of equality
but the limitations
of mindfulness once it's abstracted from
that
ethical
and much more complex psychology
that the buddha and others have uh
offered us the the risk
um is that it it becomes much more about
the receiving culture than the original
intention of the the buddhist teaching
the buddha lived in a time of great
social upheaval he in many ways was a
very political character you know
advising keems and
involved and he was you know there were
conspiracies and political conspiracies
around him
and i think we need to be careful not to
necessarily draw very literally from the
original buddhist texts because they are
texts of their time but to understand
that in translating in receiving the
teachings they can be overwhelmed by our
own
biases our own culture and i'm
particularly interested in the way in
which
the
mindfulness movement
is a sign of the
dominance of the attention economy the
way in which capitalism and
neoliberalism has commodified
and has begun to target our attention
and has a massive influence on how we um
relate to ourselves our own subjectivity
it can undermine
our ability to direct attention
and to
um
maintain a sense of our own intention
towards the world the limitations of
mindfulness are that they they tend not
to deal with that structural
um and environmental
um imposition of a very low grade
uh
engagement with the world
peter could i put that point um take
that point and alex put it to you is
there a danger that mindfulness as it
happens in the real world today is
really a sort of commercialized process
that has very little really to do with
those wider deeper you know
non-individualistic routes that it that
it has in practice
yeah i can see both sides of that um
it's
a common criticism of
mindfulness that mindfulness in itself
is essentially a moral you know if
you're a sniper in an army you can
become a better sniper by
developing your concentration to the
ability to
kill someone um that's you know
a criticism that's often leveled i i i
also have some hope uh around the
mindfulness movement i
i think there's
particularly in the context of say
corporations inviting people in
um to kind of teach mindfulness
techniques within their organization
i think they might be inviting in more
of a wolf into the flock than they they
necessarily realize uh because as we go
through a process of developing more
introspective awareness we've become
much more attuned to understanding what
really matters to us and how we really
feel about things those things are are
then are then increasing in our
awareness those can become a kind of a
spark of motivation for change we might
choose to no longer be in that
organization anymore once they're
actually forced to actually encounter
what it feels like which we've
previously been repressing
so my hope is that actually even in its
most watered-down form there is some
aspect of growing awareness that is in
itself pulling people back towards what
they really want in life and we find
this in happiness work as well when you
ask people i think
what's surprisingly radical about the
question you know what really makes you
happy is that as people start to look
into
their sources of happiness they tend to
find over and over again that it's their
connections with other people it's all
this stuff that is not within the sphere
of the kind of uh capitalist machine of
wanting you to to buy and consume more
stuff that's
everybody kind of knows when they when
they come to it with awareness that
stuff doesn't really work it doesn't
make you happy um but the things that do
are can our connection with nature our
connection with one another
our sense of kind of efficacy and agency
in the world all of those things when if
we acted and lived from those all of us
all the time we'd be living in a very
different society and i imagine would
build very different systems to sustain
it
thanks that alex let me turn a little
bit for the last part of our discussion
to uh the future about the near future
and what emerges uh beyond that and it's
wider question of whether or not what we
see at the moment is going to stay with
us meg i wonder if i might turn to you
on on this because you'll know we we all
know that over the years and the decades
various sorts of ideas about
personal health well-being
have risen and fallen some of them have
stayed with us in the western world
vegetarianism was not a particularly
widespread phenomenon i would say until
probably the late 19th 20th century when
it started to take off but it's still
very much with us and going gangbusters
on the other hand certain other types of
ways of thinking about the body and
space particularly
nudist and to give an example that was
very big in uh east germany in the 1970s
specifically uh as it happens uh has
possibly become less um uh uh less
popular in recent years although climate
change may change that in other words
looking at the wider perspective do you
see the sort of whole set of debates
about mindfulness about thinking about
the self in this way itself in this way
as part of the set of trends on personal
mental health that rise and fall or is
this one a keeper is this one here to
stay do you think
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas